vrai que c'est devenu la devenu la mode
non mais chez les pauvres d'exister des
centre-villes procès ridicule absolument
tout comme les gouttières vous avez
entendu et qui font qu'ils font exprès
de mettre la pluie sur les sdf
franchement c'est n'importe quoi ça on
va pas se mentir
[Musique]
nous sommes au fond
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
allez on vous en avait partout
maintenant c'est vrai que c'est devenu
là c'est devenu la mode
non mais chez les pauvres d'exister des
centres-villes procès ridicule
absolument tout comme les gouttières
vous a entendu qui font qu'ils font
exprès de mettre la pluie sur les sdf
bonjour c'est n'importe quoi ça on va
pas se mentir
[Musique]
c'est pitoyable parce que c'est pas ça
qui retire les gens de la rue ça les
push mais ça ne retire pas donc ça les
met dans des situations beaucoup plus
dangereuse et ce n'est plus cachez ce
sein que je ne saurais voir se cache et
soco
je ne saurais voir